to British security officials recently
turned up at the Guardian newspaper in
London their mission to oversee the
destruction of hard drives containing
documents leaked by Edward Snowden in
the weeks before that the British
government had told the paper to hand
over or destroy the documents or face
legal action it's a moment the editor of
The Guardian Alan Rusbridger describes
as one of the most bizarre in the
history of the newspaper it was quite
explicit we had to destroy it or give it
back to them what what they really
wanted was for us to give it back to
them and I explained that there were
other copies and not within the UK and
so I couldn't really see the point of
destroying one copy but because we had
other copies I was happy to destroy a
copy in London if that was going to
satisfy them it's adding to the pressure
on David Cameron's government the main
opposition Labour Party is now calling
for an urgent investigation into the use
of anti-terror powers such as those used
to detain David Miranda he's the partner
Guardian reporter Glenn Greenwald who
first published Edward Snowden's
revelations about the US and British
spying on Sunday Miranda was held for
questioning at London's Heathrow Airport
for nine hours he was released without
charge but as mobile phone laptop and
memory sticks were confiscated name of a
voltage adapter there was not one
question about terrorism not wanted ask
me about my role in the NSA documents
story Diana so command to it the
Metropolitan Police work with acting
they do under the law that the law is
there to protect us from anything that
will increase the danger of terrorism
the move could backfire david miranda is
now taking legal action glenn greenwald
is vowing to report much more
aggressively on government snooping and
the Guardian says it will continue to
cover the Snowden revelations but not
from London